welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and Logistics
first please mute yourself during the
talk but if you have a sense unmute
yourself and ask questions or we can uh
wait until the end uh to the Q&A
sessions uh second today's ddps seminar
is open to external audience uh
therefore no class by discussion is
allowed so watch out finally The Talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel um that's about it
now let me briefly introduce our speaker
today it is an honor uh to host Ching
Yao Li uh who is an assistant professor
in the department of geophysics and an
Affiliated faculty of the institute for
computational and mathematical
engineering so called icme at Stanford
uh before joining Stanford she was an
assistant professor at Princeton
University she received an undergraduate
degree uh 2013 in physics from National
Taiwan University and a PhD in
mechanical and aerospace engineering
from Princeton University she completed
her post-doctoral uh research in Geo
physics at uh Lamont Earth OB your vet
at Colombia University where she
received the Lamont postductal
Fellowship her current research focuses
on enhancing the representation of
machine learning models to tackle
multiscale problems she was the
recipient of the 2023 Google research
scholar award and 2024 slon research
Fellowship today ya will talk about
machine Precision neural networks for
multiscale Dynamics mix I'm sure we are
going to hear a wonderful talk from her
uh but before I pass the button to ya as
as a tradition to the ddps seminar let
me ask a question um in somewhat
informal questions to her uh to get to
know her about someone outside of her uh
technical reason all right uh so I
happen to know that U you like to travel
um if you can share the the the the most
favorite places you have visited so far
and um share with us why you think
so um yeah first of all thank you yonsu
for the warm introduction and invitation
I was not expecting a question uh I
guess the
travel um I really really enjoy my
travel uh in Europe in particular and
just because I've learned about it in
history in um my childhood and it was
just wonderful to to to see um
historical buildings um you also just
distract myself from the daily routine
so that's the part I really
enjoy I don't know if this is sufficient
awesome awesome yeah there's no correct
answer here so thank you so much for
sharing um your experience traveling
experience all right the stage is
yours okay yeah so yeah I'm excited to
give the today and um today I'll talk
about the work in my group uh my group
has been um developing recently uh to
enhance the representation accuracy of
neuron networks I hope I can convince
you that it is it is kind of problematic
that vanilla neuron networks suffers to
represent multikill data which motivate
us to develop machine Precision new
networks uh and this work um that we
discuss today was also published in
Journal of computational physics uh and
physical review
letters uh next slide all right so there
has been an emerging trend of research
using machine learning models to emulate
numerical simulations to substantially
reduce its computational cost and
success stories include the recent Bloom
of machine learning based weather
forecast models a classical numerical
weather forecast prediction is made by
numerically solving coup hold partial
differential equations that describe the
evolution of states and that's denoted
by Z here and in the ml emulator a
physics free machine learning model uh
is used to approximate the Dynamics that
is denoted by F here which describe the
time derivative of the states so the
machine learning model will take the
states at the previous time as input and
then predict the state at the next time
as output this approach is very
successful and after training with the
ERI weather real analysis data Deep Mind
has shown that they're able to use the a
graph new network to take the states in
the current time step and predict the
next time step and then take the next
time step um result to predict the next
next time step and so on so they show
that this can make 10day weather
forecast with Precision that is
comparable to the state-of the-art
physics based numer numerical weather
prediction model and this takes a lot of
time to train but on once it is trained
it takes negligible amount of time to
make
predictions so this is just another uh
example and image of the neuron Network
represented Global Wing field from one
of the recent machine learning weather
forecast
model and here um if you compare with
the ground truth trending data from
numerical weather prediction now you can
see that the machine learning based
weather forecast can well capture the
large scale feature right so these two
Wing fields are almost indistinguishable
but the ml based model is missing a lot
of the f scale high frequency details
that's present in the numerical data and
you even more evident in this plot so
here the is the spectrum of the wing
field the horizontal axis is the weight
number the vertical axis is the um Power
density uh the block line is the um
Spectrum from uh ERI data and the
colored lines are the Spectrum from
various different mer learning based
weather pred model so you can see that
most of the ml based model capture the
Spectrum at low wave number because they
capture a large large scale features
however they deviate from um the uh from
the Spectrum for higher wave numbers so
it's missing all the fin scale high
frequency uh details and this is even
more um severe when you look at the uh
prediction um in at day 10 um so at
daytime a lot the mismatch between the
ml based model and the um ground truth
um happens at even lower wave
numbers
whoops um I think
sorry are you still seeing my
screen no screen is gone
now sorry let me um reshare again I
don't know what happened share screen
take your time uh
window all right
yeah the first page we are seeing yeah
okay so let me go back to the
slide yeah okay so so uh what I just
describ is related to the so-called
Spectra bias of the newon network uh
speal bias refer to Neon Network's
tendency to prioritize fitting functions
with a certain frequency range uh as
demonstrated in this um 2019 paper I
really like this figure I think it's
really clear so here the blue line is
the target function and the green line
green curve is the neon prediction over
iterations so you can see that uh the
neonetwork can first fit the low
frequency function but then it take a
lot longer to fit the high frequency
signals um in the Target function and
this is this is bad news because
problems in the physical sciences often
exhibit multiscale features and neuron
networks are used because of its
property as a universal function
approximator however in practice NE
Network fail to capture f scale details
due to its spectral
bias so um a popular solution is the
soal F feature um and this um was um
proposed um in t l 2020 paper um this
for feature is composed of basis
functions of cosine and signs and it
Maps the input coordinate of the
multi-layer perception into this uh
feature before passing the um
information into the um hidden layers of
the new network and uh the the intuition
is that you can uh give some hints to
the new network that there exist a range
of frequencies that are relevant to
represent the data so you can see here
this is the original image um
represented by the regular newon Network
it looks kind of blurry just like what
we saw earlier but after applying the
Fier spec the fer
features um now the new netwk capture
all the um accurate um details in an
image
okay so that was Spectra bias and now
there's another additional uh challenge
of um machine learning emulators so this
is uh one of the machine learning based
emulator uh for cast net and this is
prediction um out to 30 days you can see
that eror start to accumulate and then
the the temperature field just we call
blow up um over
time and uh because um just recall that
in this case new network is used to
approximate the um time derivatives of
the states the Dynamics so if uh the new
network have spectr bias it could cause
errors of approximating um the states um
at smaller scales and this error can be
propagated in times and therefore make
long-term prediction terribly inaccurate
so um special buyers could be one of the
reason that can cause the blowout
Behavior we see in
emulators so um to to summarize um the
big questions that I want want to um
discuss today uh is strategies that can
tackle Spectra bias of the new network
and another question is how can we make
the neonetwork approximation as accurate
as
possible so this is um today's outline
um I'll first talk about a algorithm our
group um develops um that can um push
the error down to machine Precision um
and tackle the Spectra bias and I'll
talk about the extension for um problem
related to pdes and this is still um
preliminary and ongoing work and finally
I'll um talk about some challenges and
promising promises in this
area so okay so expressiveness of
neonetwork now here my post uh yji uh he
used a vanilla neuron Network to fit a
1D function um so here he's just a silly
um analytical function that we try to
fit and the y- axis is the U output neon
Network output x-axis is the neuron
Network input the blue line is the
function we're trying to fit the dash
red is the neuron Network prediction so
uh here the loss function quantifies the
difference between the ground truth
function and the neon prediction and you
can see that with a regular NE where the
error can go down to about 10 to
minus5 um but um you know the question
is why why does the error not get lower
when we TR for longer iterations so here
we try increasing the depth of a new
network increasing the width um we were
um always seeing a saturation of of
error like this so the question is why
why can we what's the minimum error we
can push the error down to you know NE
network if NE Network are truly
Universal function approximators it
should not have this um um should you
should have it can correspond to you
should be able to achieve arbit small
error theoretically so here we propose
the multi multi-stage new networ that
use a subsequent newon Network to
effectively learn to correct for the
errors from the first newon Network and
this multistage newon Network can
achieve much better Precision with less
number of total Neal parameters comp and
less computational cost compared to a
single new
network whoop I don't know why this is
happening but let's go back okay so
before going into the detail of the
algorithm I want to draw your attention
to this very simple explanation of the
spectral
bias um so here uh this is um the um
expression of a single layer newon
network with input X and output U um
here the W and Bs are the newon network
parameters and here um the loss function
Quantified the mean square error between
the neon neare output and the ground
truth so here we denote the Fate
transform of the um function as U hat
and uh the
Closs function can also be written in as
um the for transform of the ne
prediction so um if we um um we will
skip the derivation here but it can be
shown that um the gradient of the so
during gradient descend we know that the
loss function is updated based on the
gradient of the loss function with
respect to the neon parameters and can
be shown that the gradient of the loss
function um Decay exponentially with
higher frequencies and this is important
because it shows that the gradients
become very small for larger K and
therefore it would take extremely long
number of iterations to learn the high
frequency functions and this is a simple
explanation for the origin of neon
networks spectr
vales so to M mitigate this problem uh
it's um important to rescale the neon
weights um note that in this expression
um the exponential decay
um in is a Decay it is the this Factor
um the frequency uh divided by um W and
that determine the Decay and W is the
newon network weight so if we can
increase the uh neon Network weights um
proportionally with the frequency K that
we want to uh capture uh we can keep
this gradient large for larger K and
this can reactivate the learning of high
frequency functions so here uh in our
implementation we have a scaling uh fact
ctor called Capa and that's a multiplier
in front of the weights um of the newon
network that connects the input to the
first hidden layer um and note that this
is um similar uh to the for feature uh
implementation but here we we don't
include a cosine activation function
because that's not
necessary
so the ca is a user define parameter and
you can set the value large COA has the
effect of rescaling the input X and make
it easier to learn high frequency
functions so we can see that um with
large cut the the the new networ newor
approximation can fits the target
function um better and this was also um
shown by this paper um by jch in
2020 um in the case when Capa is smaller
um is really um struggling to fit the
taring
function so
um however uh we we are still even
though we increase the ca you're seeing
we're still missing part of the um
targeting function so um here we Chang
the activation function from holic
tangent to sign and it shows that the
fitting is much better therefore a
combination of large scaling factor and
the sinusoidal activation function gives
much better um error and we know that
this implementation uh has a similar
trending error compared to the forar
feature
net so uh one thing to be careful with
is that the network can start to
overfeed the data if you increase the ca
um um further uh so here we can see that
um if you uh just look at the trending
LW uh when you increase the scaling
Factor um you can keep minimizing the
loss um so here the Kaa is like up to
300 the loss looks very small however
this is actually quite deceiving because
if you look at the actual prediction of
the neware with larger Kaa value on the
higher resolution grid point you seeing
that it's actually overfitting the
function and have all these Wiggles so
um it's important to know that there's
actually a optimal range of Capa that um
works well um here we show the mean root
mean square error of the new network
it's a function of the um scaling Factor
Capa and you can see that the opal Capa
is related to the dominant frequency in
a in a Target function which is denoted
by f D and this is aligned with our
expectation from the Spectra bias
analysis
huh I don't know what happened let's
keep
um this
is okay it's somehow like skipping
skipping many slides I'll go back where
we are okay here's good yeah all right
so so that was for U fitting high
frequency functions
uh now uh we have another issue
independent issue to overcome so when
the new network training error is very
small um we know that the learning
become very slow right and so here is
the main idea of the multi-stage newer
Network um inspired by participation
Theory here we write the neon Network
approximative function as a
superposition of the leading order
approximation you not and the higher
order error error terms like U1 U2 Etc
so here Epsilon one is a small constant
um and Epsilon is um much much smaller
compared to Epsilon one the U not U1 uh
U2 Etc are the newon networks from
different stages so although the first
newon Network un not doesn't perfectly
fit the target function we can use a
subsequent uh newon Network U1 to learn
to correct for the residue from the
previous new network and because here
the uh us not U1 U2 um are all orders of
M21 functions so it's easy for NE
Network to capture um all these um error
terms instead of having a single neon
Network capturing all the um small
magnitude
details and note that there here's a
list of um related work with um similar
strategies um so um sequential residue
learning and multi-layer neur networks
this paper actually was is also able to
um get the error down to machine
Precision um there's also the stack uh
networks by how L and precision machine
learning so this is really um I think re
um Rising trend of research to try to um
understand what control the error of the
new
approximation okay so here is a
numerical demonstration uh we um this is
the another 1D Target function we are
trying to fit and um so here show after
one single newon Network the error of
the first newon Network um so the
magnitude is about 10 to the minus 4 the
xaxis is the input of the neuron Network
so we do a FR transform of this um error
and look at it in a frequency space so
here you can see the dominant frequency
corresponding to the error of this first
new network and then we use a second
neuron Network a subsequent newon
Network to um learn to fit the error
from the first newon Network so now the
second neon Network um with the first
one Al together has a error that's much
smaller so about 10 to the minus 8 and
one thing that's interesting is if you
look at the frequency um of this era of
the second unit where it's actually much
higher so we can look at the frequence
error in a for space it correspond to a
higher dominant frequency and then we
can repeat this procedure we use the
third newon network to learn uh the to
approximate error from the second neon
Network and now the residual um of the
three networks combined become 10 minus
11 um and the same story you know after
um all the the N networks are stacked
together uh we can achieve the error
that's close to um 10 minus minus 13 and
the now the error has a really really
high frequency so here uh is just to
show
the um the error of the approximation um
throughout iterations uh you can see
that the error convergence for this
multi-staging training scheme is a lot
faster uh with trending iterations
compared to a single newon Network
and this just shows um that um
throughout different stages the error of
the approximation gets lower at the same
time the um dominant frequency of the
error increase and this actually U we
see that it follows a power law um with
exponent one/ six and this exponent is
actually uh quite Universal uh we see
this for various different Target
function that we have tried and is
relatively um unchanged with different
sampling data and different layer
different architecture different number
of layers number of
units um I love to if you have ideas of
how to explain this exponent I would
love to chat more about it okay
so that was for very simple right like
ond um learning 1D function and here we
want to see if we can use this idea to
learn um 2D um data like um um the data
of uh flow field so here my student
jenking uh she um used the spectral
methods to uh create um the numerical
simulation as soles the this 2D
incompressible equation with Ral number
2000 and here is the vorticity field um
that evolve with with time and here is
the energy Spectrum so so we like this
example because it has the um energy
specializ spends over skilles um that
with two orders of magnitudes is a um
simple example of a multiscale problem
so here what we want to do is to just
use a multistage Network to fit a
snapshot of these flow
field so this is the um Target function
of the flow field at a particular at a
time and the here is the new networ um
representation of the data so the input
of a new networ is the coordinate and
the output of the new network is the um
um string function the flow feed
and you can see that um the the the
difference is quite small U this is the
error between the target function and
the ne
approximation the magnitude of the error
is about 10 to the minus 4 uh if you
look at this error um in space it's
quite interesting it has this Wiggles so
we look at this error in for space um
and we see that there's some dominant
frequency of um the error so here is the
Spectrum uh energy spectrum of the
ground true true data showing black and
the neuron network data showing blue and
you can see the Spectra bias so the neon
Network captured the small um wave
number um energy Spectrum but mismatch
uh has a mismatch in the high wave
number
region okay so we're going to do the
same procedure now we will use a second
new network to fit the error from this
first new network and this is the error
of after the second new network now it
has the magnitude of 10 to the minus 7
and the error of the second unit now has
a higher um dominant wave number and we
keep uh this procedure uh after the
third stage the error can be down to
close to machine Precision of the double
floating point 10 to minus 16 um and um
now has a um you can see that in energy
Spectrum the neon network uh
approximation correspond to energy
Spectrum that's aligned uh really well
with the target
function so this is just in comparison
comparing the multi-station new network
with the regular new network we show
that uh in for the energy Spectrum um
the here the red line is the um Regular
newon Network um the green line is the
multistation newon network that can um
tackle the spectr Biers and agrees very
well with the target uh function we look
at the loss convergence uh compared to
the regular single neon Network that has
a loss Lo loss value that converges over
iterations um with a multi-age newer
Network we can achieve unprecedented
accuracy and down to PR machine
Precision of the double Precision
floating
Point okay so this is a quick summary so
for uh this um data fitting problem um
the training data for the higher stage
new network comes from the error from
the previous stage and the error of the
higher stage neuron Network are usually
higher frequency functions so although
it is difficult for vanilla NE Network
to capture high frequency data we can
use a scaling Factor CA that can be
determined directly using the dominant
frequency of the uh residues and this is
um exciting for us because uh using this
multi-stage neuron Network we can tackle
the Spectra bias and Achieve um
unprecedented
accuracy okay uh just doing that again
so yeah that was um I want to emphasize
that
uh sounds um like there's lots of steps
but actually all all of these steps can
be
automated okay so um so far uh we have
talked about machine procedure new
network for Tech spected bias right uh
and um the next question is can um can
we use this for PD problems can PD
residues also be down pushed down to
verion Precision so this is a much much
harder problem to to um investigate and
and this is still ongoing work um in
particular uh I'll um in the next few
slides um I'll talk about um the
application of multi-stage new network
to physics inform new networks so for
background information uh physics
informed new network leverage new
networks expressiveness to approximate
solutions to pdes and because newon
networks are analytical functions is
derivatives um and therefore uh the PD
residues can be calculated exactly using
automated
differentiation and a new prediction
that makes the PD residue equal to zero
is um that that exactly satisfy um the
equation so throughout the trending
process the newon neor will find an
approximate representation of the PD
Solution by minimizing the loss function
that include both the PD residue and the
associated boundary conditions um and I
should add that I think um physical
networks are better for solving inverse
problems um because for forward problems
there are also many other traditional
solvers that are much faster than pins
and in the next few slides I will still
use for problem as examples to just to
explain how the multi-stage pin works
but in the end I will talk about a the
impact of this approach for a inverse
problem okay so um before talking about
the detail I want to emphasize again the
importance of the scale ing Factor so
here is the um example of um the poison
equation and um this is nice example
because we know the exact
solution so here uh is the pink solution
of the vanilla pin um to the poison
equation and it has a prediction error
about 10 to minus 4 uh because this
solution has high frequency features um
I want to just um remind you that due to
the Spectra bias is harder for pin to
approxim made a solution U like this um
but what we can do again is to um change
this scaling Factor so here if we U make
the scaling Factor um that's closer to
the um dominant frequency in this um um
sourcing term uh six Pi now we can
reduce the error by two orders of
magnitude just by changing this um
scaling Factor okay so okay so how do we
apply multi-stage um idea to pins we
know that for the previous uh regression
data fitting problem right the trending
data for the higher stage NE comes from
the error of the previous stage and that
can be calculated if you know the if you
know the target function if you know the
ground
truth but for soling PDS we we don't
know the solution right we we don't we
want to find the solution so we do not
know the target function so uh in the
case when you don't have any Target
function how do we design the higher
stage Network What would would be the
training
data okay so I'll explain that in the
next few slides and using this simple
example so here's a simple linear OD and
again the residue is just um the the
rewriting the equation um here so this
example also is quite nice it has the
exact solution um and uh we will Define
the solution error as the difference
between and predicted solution with the
this exact solution again um this uh
Gray colored text here and that it's not
going to be seen by the newon network
I'm showing here just for validating our
result okay so here is the um the Ping
result uh PR prediction compared to the
exact solution and uh after the the
first stage uh so here uh is the PD
residue um as a function of uh input X
and here uh we did a we look at the
residue in a fre domain so we can see
it's dominant frequency uh interestingly
um here we can calculate the solution
error by comparing the the red and the
blue lines and then uh here we uh this
is the solution error uh we can also
look at the solution error in the
frequency space again uh this lower
panel in Gray here is not seen by the
algorithm I'm just showing here for for
your um
information so one thing interesting we
you see here is that the dominant
frequency of the PD residue is close to
the dominant frequency
the error of the solution another thing
is that the error of the solution um the
magnitude of the uh residue is larger
compared to the magnitude of the error
of the
solution okay so we know that uh to
design a multi-staging neetwork we need
to specify the orders of magnitude of
the um error for the um Second Stage
solution which is this um Epsilon one
parameter
and um the question here is how do we
estimate um this magnitude of S11 with
the absence of um ground true solution
so here uh we can plug in this solution
Ando into the original PD and by doing
so we can obtain a new PD where the
right hand side is simply uh the PD
residue itself from the original
equation um so the first neuron
Network's PD residue um gives the can
gives the pde for the second um stage
neon Network that solves for the higher
stage um term
U1 and moreover uh the magnitude of the
dominant term um in the left hand side
um in this case is this first derivative
term um this term can be estimated um as
the magnitude of uh U1 over um X the X
length scale of U1 which is related to
the dominant frequency of U1 so um if we
want to balance um in this equation the
dominant terms are these two highlighted
in in Blue by balancing these two
dominant terms we can estimate that the
magnitude of the solution um error
Epsilon one um based on um the magnitude
of the equation residue and the
frequency of the PD residue so we have
all the information uh that we need to
estimate this ES1
parameter okay and again all this
procedure can be automated um so now you
might ask this is works for um you know
OD with first derivative U how about
higher order derivatives for higher
order derivatives you can apply this
very s um similar strategy um so here
instead of estimating term that has like
U one overx you will have like one overx
to the power of n where n is the number
of derivatives um in the in this
term okay so uh a natural question is
how about um nonlinear
equations right um here is uh we we
discussed that in our paper as well um
here is a simple example where you have
a u Square term in your
pde um it turns out um if you have a
equation like this um you can just
follow the same procedure and then when
you write down the second stage um pte
uh to train the um Second Stage neur
network uh you'll see that because the
Epsilon one parameter is much smaller
than one so all these nonlinear terms
that involve U1 um will fall into a
higher order Epsilon one square term and
this can be generally disregarded so
this suggest that although despite the
nonlinearity of the original equation
the government equation for the higher
stage Network essentially can become a
linear equation because this term is
negligible and therefore the similar
strategies that I just described would
apply
here and uh here I'm just mentioning the
um basic intuitions of um our approach
uh if you want to see more details uh
you can look at section 3.1.2 in our
paper for the form more
derivations okay so this is just to show
the result um here we have all we need
to conduct the multistage training for
Pins uh we know that um the frequency um
so this is a um the the PD we trying to
solve uh this is the uh first stage res
PD residue and uh this is the error of
the first stage PD solution uh we know
that the frequency of the higher stage
solution should be close to the
frequency of the residue and using uh
this second equation we can estimate the
magnitude of Epsilon one which is the
magnitude of the higher stage solution
so now we have all the information
needed needed to optimize the second new
network and here we just uh showing that
this works very well so the um
prediction from the um Second Stage new
network agrees very well with the
expected result and again the here the
error um is not provided as the trending
data because um um we don't we don't U
the new network doesn't see the um data
when training the new network can only
predict um the um the the the solution
because it's solving the PD for the
second stage NE
Network so and here just show after um
two stages the multi-stage solution has
an eror that's close to 10 to the minus
13 and um after uh more stages the
solution can be um the error of res
solution can approach 10 to the power of
16 which is close to machine Precision
of double floating
points okay so this is just a quick
summary uh previously for regression
problem the trending data for higher
stages come from the error of the
previous stage and that can be
calculated from the ground truth Target
function for Ping the ground truth is
not available for calculating the error
however the PD residue from the previous
stage neur can be used to estimate the
magnitude and frequency of the higher
stage PD solution and the PD of the
higher stage neur can be written in
terms of the PD residue of the previous
stage new network so we have all the
information uh we need from previous
stage to train the next stage and
perform multi-stage training for um P
for the um p network um again all this
procedure can be
automated okay so this is just to show
the scaling of the error um here you can
U even enhance the algorithm by adding
um the gradient of the residue in the
loss function term it's also called
gings so here if you look at the um
throughout subsequent stages the error
of the solution uh compared to the
dominant frequency of the error uh you
can see it also follows the power law um
for regression problem we saw the power
has like one over six um exponent uh
here uh with the addition of PD loss in
the cost function uh we have a steeper
um slope it's about close to one over
eight okay so uh that was for Ping uh
with 1D um um with uh OD and here is a
simple pde um example right so here we
have um a diffusion diffusion equation
uh like this where we also have the have
an analytical solution and here you can
see um the first stage um ping error is
about 10 to the power of minus 4 after
uh three stages on the error um can be
pushed down to 10 to the minus 9 and
this is just to show the same um scaling
law of the error of the solution versus
the dominant frequency of the
errors
okay so this is the um introduction of
how this um multi-stage High Precision
neon Network work and um um so what can
this um you know all the example I
showed so far are the example where we
already have analytical Solutions so um
in practice what can we use this High
Precision new network um for and here I
want to show example where it can be
used to solve some very um challenging
PD so it can actually be used to find
some PD solutions that are otherwise
quite difficult to find with classical
methods um as an example um so I'll talk
about um the uh Navia Stokes equation um
Navia Stokes equation is widely used um
in various applications in science and
engineering right for two more than uh
two centuries uh it's also U my favor
equations um in the world because of
because of its
universality however um there are also
many unsolved uh questions concerning
the fundamental behavior of the navus do
equation in particular we do not know if
the nous do equation always exist a um
um solution uh that always exist is a
solution for um any smooth bound initial
condition so um one of the um pathway uh
to tackle this problem is to uh find a
solution to the N St equation that can
blow up at finite time if one can find
this example that would be a counter um
example of the um the statement that N
St equation always exist a unique and
smooth solution at any times so here we
want to um see if our high Precision
multi NE Network can be used to find
blowout Solutions um and uh this um
question um this open question are also
very important uh for not only for Navia
Stokes but also the Oilers
equation let's go back so for oers
equation uh this will be the focus of
the next few slides and uh this work was
also recently published in physical
review
letters okay so this is the Oilers
equation uh this simply the Navia Stokes
equation with uh zero viscosity a open
question for this question uh that
remains unsolved for over a century is
whether a smooth and finite energy
initial condition can blow up in finite
time in the past decades there has been
several progress U made by direct
numerical simulations and that suggest
um Singularity formation uh for the oil
equation however uh you can imagine that
near the time of blowing up near the
time of Singularity the time and space
resolution needed to Res resolve the um
Dynamics are extremely high so you need
really really find resolution to resolve
the singularity the smallest um lens
scale um and the largest um scale can
spend over more than 12 quars of
magnitude so this is a this posted a
multiscale numerical challenge to this
problem and in the next few slides I
will show how we can tackle this problem
with a multi-stage fys formul network
so um we first um reduce the
dimensionality so we are working in a
self-similar domain and here uh we use a
physial network to approximate uh four
parameters we want to solve for as a
function of two um self similar input
coordinate so throughout the trending
iterations the algorithm will search for
the four solution profiles that satisfy
the self-similar um Oilers equation and
I want to emphasize that this is not not
a this is not a forward problem because
uh in this um set of equation we have a
critical unknown parameter we have a
lond parameter in the set of equations
so the search for the solution along
with this unknown parameter is a inverse
problem instead of a forward
problem and I will skip a lot of
numerical details uh here uh these are
um documented in the supplementary
material of our paper
but um our newon Network can so see that
is again so this is a loss versus
iteration and the um convergence of the
neon Network approximation of the
solution over iterations so our new
network can numerically found can numer
to find um a set of approximate smooth
self similar solutions that exhibit
singularities to the oers equation and
this is one of the example where neuron
network has found PD solutions that had
not been found before with other more
classical methods uh here you can um
calculate the um accuracy of a solution
by substitute the newon network of
solution into the um PD and look at the
PD residues so uh this uh Quantum
Quantum magazine article uh this uh they
did a good job explaining the background
of this problem and our progress and um
Charles feferman uh he's not directly
involved in this work he's the author of
the um statement of exist distance and
smoothness of the nav equation uh so he
mentioned in uh the quantum um article
that our result is um um is quantitative
and ISE precise and has a good chance of
being made rigorous so this is uh very
um exciting to us because this is a
possible strategy to U tackle various
blow problem where um the classical um
simulation is
difficult okay um so so just want to um
sum up by saying that there has been uh
several challenges um in this general
area of high Precision learning um and
there are also a lot of progress that's
been made um so in from different angles
uh for example uh there's many many um
work that focus on how to enhance the
function approximation error and there
also um um paper that tackles how to do
faster optimization like second order
optimization method I think marus is
actually giving a talk in this seminar
series next week um look forward to that
and there's also um how to approximate
high frequency functions uh we already
mentioned this paper previously uh for
in a context of pin there's um various
work that discuss how to determine the
uh how to weight different terms uh in
the loss function and the overall goal
here is to make the convergence rate in
for different terms in the loss function
roughly compar
and there's also um some work focus on
how to optim op um have a strategy that
optimize the sampling of cocation point
and how do you choose optimal activation
functions of new network uh finally uh
there are also it's work by Mishra that
um look at um in addition whether we can
say something about the error bound of
the solution based on the PD
residue okay so I'll encourage you to
check out all these um papers
and to sum up um this talk um we that
multistation Network can boost
approximation accuracy it can tackle
spectal bias and um enhance the um neon
neare Precision to machine Precision it
doesn't uh it takes less computational
cost in a single new networ and this is
useful um for representation represent
representing um flow that exhibit
multiscale features we have also applied
to find um blowout solutions to Oiler
and this is a um challenging multiscale
problem uh in the future uh we're
interested in systematic study of um the
use of these for various types of pdes
and we also want to see uh if we can use
this to improve surrogate model so how
can this you know very precise neur
Network be uh can be how can it be used
to help to mitigate error um and
instabilities in the U machine learning
based um
emulators and yeah so finally um I want
to thank my wonderful group members uh
Yan Wan is um really the core developer
of the deep learning algorithm um none
of the result would be possible without
without him and uh jenking and Charlie
are my students who contributed
substantially to the Deep learning
algorithms uh our code so many people
ask me about the code and it is open
source available uh if you want to try
it you can go to this link um and I'll
be very happy to answer any
questions thank you stop here thank you
thank you so much for the wonderful talk
uh yeah that was uh very informal and
I'm sure everyone here lears a lot okay
let's have a Q&A sessions um I don't see
any questions in the chat room um so if
you have questions please unmute
yourself ask questions don't be shy oh
yeah
Lucas just asked the questions he said
thanks a lot for the presentation it was
very clear and informative where can we
find the slides of the presentations um
okay we are going to make this uh video
like the recorded Video available in the
YouTube uh you can check it there or or
uh ya do you mind share your slides to
audience uh yeah what would be the best
way to do that um you you can p that to
me um and then you
know yeah I can yeah I'll forward to the
slides no problem yeah all right thank
you for the question Lucas um hi this is
Jerome fber thank you for the
presentation I was just uh struck a
little bit by the fact that um you know
there's a relationship it seems between
um doing the uh the second level mural
Network and um maybe the norm that
you're using for the error right if you
maybe use for the PD it's natural to use
like the H1 Norm so it to include like
the the gradients in the error um so I
was just wondering if you had some
thoughts on
that so I couldn't hear exactly every
word let me try it again can you hear me
now
yeah but oh yeah so I was um just
thinking that uh um there's a
relationship between what you're doing
and like the choice of the norm you use
for measuring the error and like in the
PBE case at least it's would be natural
to use like the H1 Norm so you would
include the gradients you know the
difference in the gradients and the um
in the error which would naturally tend
to um grab a lot more of the high
frequency terms so I just wondered if
you if you had thought about that and uh
you know if there was a a relationship
there that you had uh
explored yeah you're talking about how
how to report errors right and uh yeah
because that that how you decide on the
error like turn determines how the thing
is uh is trained
right right right the error the training
is using L L2 actually sometimes we use
LP um and the the pre yeah our our way
of that is a good question yeah we can
look at if you used if you used L you
know the H1 Norm which is like is like
you know the square of the error plus
the square of the error in the gradients
then it would naturally which is n which
is the natural one that we use for like
pdes for like second order pdes would
would tend to capture a lot of the error
that just using the L2 Norm would miss
right I I think this is a good good good
good suggestion yeah we we could
definitely we you know we can definitely
calculate H1 error without problem yeah
so yeah I will be to see there's a what
I'm trying to say is there a
relationship between doing that sort of
um second level of uh neural networks
and including say a higher order terms
in the error matx um but both of them
are attempting to train uh towards uh
you know something that captures High
higher frequency terms
more yeah oh that's a good that's a good
um suggestion we we have not really as
calculate um you know H1 eror so far far
is still ongoing work and we just to use
really look at a simple difference
between but yeah I I see what your I see
your point um I think is a good thing to
to do we can definitely yeah report yeah
thank you um Robert I know you put the
question in the chat room but do you
want to unmute yourself and then ask
yeah sure so um you mentioned at the
start of your talk maybe we can talk
after um you wanting to invest instigate
why you're seeing that um Alpha
coefficient appearing over and over
again with your graphs have you looked
into any of the research on the
empirical scaling laws of neural
networks yeah yeah uh so the empirical
uh the empirical um deep scaling
convergence laws and that's yeah yeah
what can you rem me what's the alpha
value on there or is interestingly the
alpha values there um seem to work
something like a condition
um an analog for like mathematical
problems in that they are constant for
the problem being discussed but are
independent of the network architecture
used but only sometimes there's like
research that shows that lstms and
Transformers for example have a
four-fold difference in their
coefficients
interesting yeah yeah yeah I think here
um I think there there's a there yeah
this is something uh I'm really curious
to see because in our case is it's
actually quite consistent with what we
see um that the independence of the um
architecture and the depth and WID but
so yeah I've been looking at it for a
while it's like you know we we can talk
afterwards but basically the the other
questions I had I just wanted to kind of
alert you into that because I think
there's a connection to what you're
doing there and I also like wanted to
ask um do you have any insights about
how the size of the network affects the
frequency response of your networks if I
take my if I say add a thousand times
more parameters to my network and It
capture more spectral
modes I really like this question
because um I had that exact same
question like a year ago
um you know like if we draw analogy to
fua Series right you would think that
more terms you would you would be able
to capture like a wi broader range of
frequencies interestingly um if we let's
do a simple um test simple thought Pro
thought experiment if we just have one
single um hidden layer and then replace
all the activation function by sign
signs so it's like close to like a frea
series and you ask the question can
increasing number of um neurons uh um
increase the ability for a neuron or to
capture higher frequency data the answer
is actually no because that depends on
how you initialize the new network and
optimate optimization procedure it's
really the the architecture itself is
fine but it's the the way neac will
learn how to optimize parameters that's
like limiting its represent
representation
accuracy so that's why that's why in our
in our case we initially we just
increase the depth and width and that
has like I think you will also see a
scaling law actually right but the
exponent is not as large as six yeah not
scaling the scalings are usually really
really poor like I I wonder and this
brings into the reason I asked the third
question there is how do you apply this
idea to a problem where you can't really
do a frequency analysis like say I
wanted to take and do a multi-stage
network for something like an LM how
could I do that without being able to
analyze the
Kappa let see that's a very good
question so if you have I think I think
what the llms are seeing are basically
the same phenomena that you were seeing
on these physics problems right they
have some problem and you read the
studies on how they suddenly things
suddenly grock like it really sounds to
me for someone who has a physics basis
as in they've suddenly discovered a
frequency mode of the underlying data
and you look at these networks a lot
like they usually smooth over noise
until they suddenly find a signal in the
noise which can be like analogous to
suddenly finding the frequency in a
feature space where this all suddenly
makes sense but it'd be really
interesting and we have lots of problems
around here where I'd love to apply a
tech like this I've spent like you know
two years trying to fit a network to
machine Precision or something and
failing um and like no one has been able
to like find a network that can like R
down so I'm really excited by this but
we have problems where you can't do a
frequency analysis um to find what the
dominant frequency
is I'm yeah I'm very interested and and
um intrigued by your question um so in
the lfm then the question is what's the
what does it mean when a new network is
of low
Precision yeah right like is it also
fitting some like what does it mean that
what's the part that's it's not fitting
yeah I don't know to answer I'm just
curious yeah so we can talk more okay of
them all right thank you for the
question and answer uh that's wonderful
any other questions from audience
I think William you raised a hand one
time and if you're still there yeah I
guess it was kind of somewhat related to
what you were talking about I was
curious if uh when you're implementing
it if you needed to go through and like
tune each autoencoder architecture as
you're going through and adding these
extra levels but it sounds like um if
you just feed in the data it doesn't
architecture doesn't matter if you feed
in the errors the actual architecture
does does matter that much it's just
what you're training
on exactly like the there's no the only
thing that we have to decide there all
the parameters like the
scaling factor that tune the um the
weights of the new network of the higher
stage new network those can be
determined just from the the result of
previous stage so those are not not
really the tuning parameter but one
thing we do have to decide is is when to
stop the training of a particular stage
so that is um still we we we kind of
decide
manually um it would be really good to
have a way to automate that process I
don't know if that
answer yeah yeah definitely thank
you I have one questions uh for the
Multistate pins uh you have to provide
some collocation points as well uh do
you see you know your
multistat pins convergence Behavior
depending on the um the number of
collocations and position location of
the location points as well have you
probably you have done some study very
this is actually a very important
question um so if we uh actually for the
Ping case we have done something almost
similar to the regression problem the
first thing we try is increasing the
collocation point and we see that error
doesn't really come like an error goes
down but there's a limit of the error of
this of the PD solution um so then we we
we know then then that's when we know
the limitation of the error is no longer
coming from collocation point it's the
architect it's the optimization of the
network it's like not learning these
high frequency features so then when we
add the second stage Network we have to
still do the same experiment we have to
see make sure we have enough collocation
point so it's not limited the accuracy
is not limited by the number of
collocation point it's limited by the
optimization of the um weight and
bias oh so you're you're not using the
same collocation point set from the
previous St you always go back and then
try to find out the you know what is the
enough like
the they don't have to be the same they
don't have to be the same but but but I
think it's easier if we just use the
highest density of points you know it's
a little bit like the regression problem
the the co the downside is is that it
increase the communicational
time um if you just use highest possible
closure Point density in the beginning
so in the beginning you can use less and
in the higher stage you need to use more
points right right I think regular
problem is it's really not it's really
too expensive to do this um it's really
for this special type of PD you really
need High precision and then inverse
problem where deriving a joint for this
couple on is is challenging that's the
type of problem where I see it's
beneficial right right I'm I'm just
curious you know the pins usually takes
a long time to you know get the
converged Solutions how about your
Multistate
pins um any benefit of accelerating that
training at all uh so depend on what you
meant by accelerate if you ask the for
the same Precision what's the
computational time compared to regular
pin the answer is yes it's faster right
yeah but like
uh if you compare that with a
traditional PDS over then that is
definitely not like I don't I wouldn't
recommend using this to solve for
example like diffusion
equation that was like for showing how
this work work like a simple example
where you have analytical solution
right all right oh thank you um the
robot you seems to have one other
questions I have like 18 questions so
that's
fine just one more okay well so like um
the ne the last question I have there is
um what happens have you ever had the
network predict the Kappa figure for you
during training of the residual
I think it is kind of been predicted by
the new network because the Kaa is
determined from the outcome of the
previous stage like usually so if the
network could predict the Capa like if
I'm if I'm training the residual the
first residual Network and then the
second residual if they're each picking
their own Kappa um that would offer a
way for you to apply this to problems
where there isn't a clear for analysis
analog because in those situations you
can't calculate that explicitly but if
the network could find it during its own
training that would give a mechanism for
this to have way more generalizability
to a whole host of different
problems I see um that's a really
really good point um it it can I think
so it this depends on I think it's
related to the question of the scaling
law because the scaling law actually
gives you you can get track down the
scaling law and then find out what's the
ca for the error so yes then if you know
the error of the first Network you can
kind of estimate the ca yeah that's
that's that's a really good point like H
this is such a cool idea okay yeah but I
still don't you know I I don't know how
univers like we we question I'm really
interested in is how why is there
scaling law for this like why is it one
over six like we have empirically show
if like is it un like how Universal is
it when does it break down right this
kind of question I'm very interested in
I I'm extremely interested in this well
it this the empirical scaling laws and
the fact that these coefficients keep
appearing over and over again is driving
me crazy and I'm glad that at least
someone with a mathematical background
is looking at it I would like to chat
more yet
touch I mean my following questions to
that those discussions between you would
be um even though even though you know
those C value can be induced from the
previous training by looking at the
residual uh you know
Dynamics uh and therefore we can apply
that to the problems where the 4E
analysis is not available um but still
llm um I don't see how is it it is
applicable to there oh so it's there's
there's there's research that shows that
um they've can do like math itical
analysis backing out stuff in llms and
they can show that um at least English
seems to work on a 42 dimensional
manifold that we don't understand but
they can do like analysis of convergence
laws and various stuff to show that hey
like there is like a 42 dimensional
space that thought seems to occur in and
with doing Vector operations in that
space you can do stuff to so like we
can't understand it but there is a high
dimensional space um where like an fft
should apply we don't know what it is
and the networks can't approximate it
well but like all these ideas
um should apply to those spaces as well
like I think that some again I wrote it
in the chat like I've tried for a while
to get networks to do a rever a
convergence thing like you're describing
and I've never been able to get it to
work just kind of on the side while I'm
doing other things um I really think the
frequency analysis is very very key to
finally getting like a spectral and
multi scale type thing working here I
think that is the key thing is you've
added something to the network that
allows you to capture different modes
explicitly and that is what is making
the whole process work and that's what G
is giving you convergence factors the
scaling factors that are factors of 10
bigger than anything else I've seen when
I'm looking at convergent stuff
elsewhere in
literature well I mean that's a cool
idea of you know those English for
example can be embedded into the 42
dimensional vectors space but I still
don't see how uh that is can be used to
you know provide some residual
informations unless there is some sort
of governing equations to um you know
guide those residual oh yeah of course
well the first example did like they uh
showed example um in the beginning where
you get able to do it without having the
governing residuals residual equations
you can just look at the residuals for
the problem and we have those for things
like L stand so I me we have those for
every problem so there's a general
result from the thing so even though we
don't have the governing equations um
actual data you can still apply it
directly from the data right okay cool
any other questions it's past the time
unfortunately I'm sure um many exciting
questions will come up but we have to
wrap up soon so maybe one more questions
we can
take well if not let's thank our speaker
uh ya for the wonderful talk and
wonderful Q&A sessions and I'm sure um
that many people is going to be
interested in your work Y and future
collaborations um hopefully comes out um
you know initiated by this seminar yeah
thank you y and thank you Robert for the
the point about L I'm very interested I
need to learn more about it so awesome
awesome okay all right well thank you
yeah with that we conclude the talk yeah
thank you see you bye